Bell claims that her divorce was a
necessary step in the pursuit of
authenticity she says that in order to
be authentic and to live the life you
want to live sometimes you have to break
your marriage vows and destroy your
family we hear a lot about authenticity
these days and it's always in this
context to be authentic is to be selfish
the authentic path is the most
convenient path but this is not
authenticity not in any meaningful way
but there is a higher authenticity right
there is an authenticity that we should
actually strive towards and that is the
authentic authenticity of a virtuous
life the authenticity of faithfulness
and love and sacrifice the authenticity
of Promises Kept and vows upheld true
authenticity can be found in the pursuit
of something greater than yourself